so if someone has actually never seen
anything that you've done what is the
first thing you want them watching and
why
the tree of life
um i think that's a film for me that is
more than a film it's more than a
performance it's like terence malik
wrote a poem
and um
filmed me
and captured me in a way that
uh
it's gonna i can't even really talk
about without getting emotional so it's
very it's a very emotional film for me
it's definitely the film that um
when i'm gone i would like people to um
remember me bye
yeah it's also a fantastic movie um
so you're a producer on this and i'm
curious and also you came up with the
idea this is like all you um at what
point in the when you were shooting some
of the stunts you're on top of like
you're in a crane you're being lifted up
at any point were you like
what am i doing how did i get here and
how did i allow myself to do this
absolutely i mean it's not like listen
it's not a secret dream of mine to be an
action star steve really it's like i was
it literally came from me being on the
jury at can and going they don't make
movies with female ensembles action
movies that that like aren't comedies or
like a joke you know like why don't we
make a film where it takes it seriously
i know the woman i played in zero dark
thirty i know women who currently work
in espionage it's kind of never been
addressed in a way um so i wanted to do
it i also wanted to make a film where
the actresses were the owners of the
film we made it outside a studio system
we made it independently we raised the
money
and we made it for a fraction
like the tiniest budget compared to what
they're normally made for so it was like
an experiment i think um many and many
times i was like up on this crane going
how did i get myself into this
i was like i watched you know i see you
doing the stunt i'm like are you [ __ ]
kidding like what wait what i had to go
to the hospital
for real for real one day i literally
i'm not because also to all the crews
looking at me and i'm like it was my
idea so i couldn't like half-ass
anything i had to like really show up i
had to do everything i didn't want to
let anyone down
and we were doing a fight scene and i
was supposed to hit my head on the
ground it was a marble ground and i
misjudged i was like in the moment and i
misjudged the distance and i
hit my head on the marble and i heard a
crack
that everyone in the room heard
we stopped my stunt um
double came up to me and she's like she
didn't speak great english so she goes
i'm sorry i have to put it back in your
head
like is something hanging out of my head
um
and it was just i think goodness it was
just the bruise i guess that she was
pushing back in my head but they they
told me i was like no let's keep going
they're like no you're going to the
hospital
so yeah
yeah it was no joke
uh
uh i
right um so i'm being given the rap
signal but i just real quick um i really
appreciated that you made this because
um
i think that more like this is great to
see like all these women kicking ass on
screen um and i'm just curious what are
you thinking about for producing in the
future like what are how did this
inspire you to do more if you you know
what i mean well this has been a really
exciting year because we've had you know
we have 355 we have um the eyes of tammy
fay
um come out that we produce at freckle
films and i'm working right now on
george and tammy you know the mini
series about george jones and tammy
winnett i'm really excited about doing
anything that feels a bit rebellious
um i find sometimes and i know it can be
a little
complicated for an industry that's
worked in one way for so long like even
this like having the actresses own the
film and and
it's never really been that there's
always been some executive in some
office somewhere saying who has value
and what when their shelf life expires
so this idea that we can be like okay
the artist should own their work that's
exciting um
if i can do anything that feels a little
i'm kind of rebellious i kind of like
pushing against rules i don't like to be
told
this is the box everyone needs to be in
and you know everyone stay in your lane
i like being like well why are there
lanes to begin with let's color outside
the lines
um and supposedly i mean they haven't
kicked me out of the industry yet so
thank goodness but yeah i can i want to
continue coloring outside the lines
i love it um listen congrats uh great to
see you oh i want to know when you guys
are filming the division because i
really want to see that movie i want to
know that too i mean rawson's working on
the script
we're all hanging in there we're linking
arms where we want to get it made i mean
i also i want to work with jake he's
great
and we've been talking about this for a
long time so
yes we are definite we're all committed
and we're loyal to we're loyal i mean
george and tammy i got attached to in
2011. tammy fay i i worked on for seven
years before we started filming once i
attached my i'm a loyal mf so i am loyal
to the division
yeah i know rosen's working on the
script because he told me um and i know
some people that saw ambulance the new
michael bay and they raved about it and
they said jake is phenomenal at it so i
yeah but he's kind of talented yeah kind
of
i mean if only you know he wasn't just
so disgusting to look at and he had a
little bit more talent he'd be fine
right exactly
but it's you know it's good though that
he's riding this like wave of you know
uh but it's nice because i didn't like
six underground but everyone who saw
ambulance uh tells me how good it is
okay i'm excited to see that yeah all
right let me go um all right bye steve
later
you